what's up
what's up guys how's everybody doing
is everybody holding up yeah i'm like
myself
super bright
okay
is
[Music]
okay
[Music]
it's nothing it's nothing
it's not ignored
you guys you know it's always been there
it's always been there
like ever since i had ever since i first
started comics explain
i've never been able to start a stream
without it causing problems
so fixed awesome cool okay let's uh
let's turn that light down because
it looks like jesus is standing back
there
uh let's turn this light down here there
we go
let me turn it up a little smidge um
okay uh
is the stream in 720p
surely the stream's not at 720p
it is a 720p all right um give me one
give me one second guys give me
like one second okay
good lord good
lord like it's always it's always it's
always
struggle problems always struggle
problems
always struggle problems and i need to
turn on
slow mode here
actually you know what i kind of like it
going super fast
i kind of like the the stream
going a bit bonkers i kind of i kind of
like that
um
but uh but yeah so yeah you shouldn't
hear the echo anymore
everything should be okay so um but the
stream should also be
so it should be 1080p no 720p is not
okay now here's a cool thing
when we get back to colorado and this is
going to be crazy when we get back to
colorado
my streams are going to be insane
because our neighborhood has
10 gig internet i'm gonna be streaming
it like 4k
like crisp clean 4k i mean like sharp
man that that just crispy razor sharp
uh 4k it's gonna be it's gonna be nuts
it's gonna be awesome but anyway guys
okay so uh
wandavision one division
division episode four was absolutely
ends or episode five it was absolutely
insane
uh the title has spoilers right so if
you're in this chat don't get pissed off
that we go over spoilers
that's your fault not mine because you
didn't have sense enough to read the
title so
uh let's see it's really nice that
marvel used the 80s quicksilver as well
yeah yeah yeah 10 gig like
you have one gig fiber optic internet we
have 10 gig and it's 10 gig up and 10
gig down it's
it's linear like it's it's it's nuts oh
nathan where are you at in colorado are
you in uh like longmont because i know
longmont
has fiber optic internet but uh mic
blockage
i guess i could lower my mic a little
bit uh
there we go and like block my face with
my microphone
i mean at the end of the day though all
you guys really care about is my voice
you don't care about my face
you don't
not fooling me
[Laughter]
but um but yeah
uh we should hang out yeah when i get
back into town that's definitely
that's definitely a thing um yeah no
vision is not alive
vision is definitely not alive um
he's definitely dead like we we know
that like we definitely know that
the morning voice everything the light
touches
is our kingdom simba you're breathtaking
[Laughter]
um yeah i finally got a haircut and
everything recently i need to work on
these i got these pock marks and crap
all over my face i need to fix
that but uh yeah so how many of you guys
have seen episode five of wanda vision
i'm assuming you have because you're
here but how many of you guys have seen
episode number five
it's kinda bonkers it's kinda bonkers
episode number five was was pretty crazy
uh yeah she was definitely pissed of
captain marvel
like it was it was one of those things
that i kind of observed okay so there's
a few things that i've noticed
about agnes right a few things that i've
noticed about agnes did you guys notice
that
in this uh she left the town
did you guys notice that in this episode
of wandavision
that the only thing that surprised agnes
about what wanda could do was
potentially resurrecting the dead
she was not surprised about anything
else she was not surprised by anything
else
but yeah quick silver man evan peters so
you know what
for for this q a we're going to change
things up a little bit we're going to
change things up a little bit
here's my question for you guys this is
a serious question
this is an important question
do you guys think that marvel is using
evan peters like
he's he's the first x-man to be
introduced
into the marvel cinematic universe or do
you think it's just kind of like a hand
wavy thing and he's not going to be on
the show for
for very long what do you guys think
agnes was scared of wand in that
instance yeah she was pretty freaked out
by wanda in that instance
yeah give me blue marvel in the mcu man
like i really want to see blue marvel
in the the marvel cinematic universe you
think your phone is precisely possessing
uh wanda at times maybe
like maybe but
um okay so so in order to make this
answer
easier in order to make this answer
easier because because everybody's
typing in order to make this easier
if you think that evan peters is
is marvel introducing the x-men into the
mcu
type in mcu if you think that them
enter you know showing evan peters on
wandavision is just kind of a hand wavy
thing
type fox that way it's easier to tell
so mcu if you think he's here to stay
fox if you think he's only gonna appear
for a short time
so uh let's see
they did a astro engineer yeah okay
so i think mcu everywhere
[Laughter]
everybody's saying mcu
[Laughter]
like there's like three people who said
fox everybody's just like i'm so um
everybody's saying him to you god i love
i love talking to you guys on live
streams it's so fun
i miss doing these live streams but it's
so fun talking to you guys
it's always super enjoyable you guys are
always a hoot talking to you all on
on live streams it's always a blast
because i always wonder what you guys
are doing okay
here's my question what are you guys
doing right now you guys at work you
guys at home
what are you guys doing right now
because i'm always curious what you guys
are doing when you guys are watching my
live streams
right you taking a break from work did
you just get home
uh you think agnes is possessed by
nightmare or mephisto really
i think she's just a legitimate witch i
think she's just like a straight
legitimate witch i think that's really
all she is um
watching live at 5 30 in the morning
here we're here in a lecture
mafia man veto is in a lecture
work you're at work working at home
still at work
dinner time
[Laughter]
playing call of duty i haven't played
that game in a long time uh
school home in the uk it's 9 30
and that's right you guys are five hours
ahead uh you're buying bitcoin
um just picked up your kids
yeah that's wild so um
but yeah like i don't i don't think um
i don't think i don't think agnes is
possessed by nightmare or mephisto i
think agnes is just agnes
like i think she lived in west view and
she's always kind of being caught up
with
if you guys do want to know my theories
and stuff though um you can check them
out on pop culture explained
where i have all my my one division
theories and everything i mean don't
leave right now
but like they're they're all on pop
culture explain we just released one
maybe 30 minutes ago 20 minutes ago or
something like that so there was one
that just came out
um what if there is someone else who
needed wanda
off topic from vision arguments so he or
she
brings in quicksilver but couldn't bring
pietro from the dead so
bring one from another reality um
i mean that's the thing like like my
thought was it was basically just
wanda i don't know i mean there's
there's no real concrete explanation you
can give
for why eric peter's quicksilver from
fox
is in one division now like there's no
concrete explanation you can give
for that um
yeah there's no there's no quick
explanation that you that you can offer
for that i mean
i don't know uh monica does have her
powers did you guys catch on to that
monica rambo has her powers she got her
abilities
honestly i think she got her abilities
because it was a combination of her
being touched by the power of wanda
and being thrown through the force field
i think that's how she got her powers
but she's basically she's basically
spectrum now
which is cool
um evan peters yeah i know i keep saying
eric peters
evan peters yeah um
people are just like it's actually evan
peters rob
uh but yeah is monica gonna show her
powers i don't know because i don't even
think she knows she has them
um she we might find out that she has
them but i don't even think that she
knows that she has them
so yes this is a fake live stream i am i
am using my
my time travel capabilities and
uh i am answering questions that i know
people are going to ask
in three hours
my superpower your superpower is
obviously not common sense
um so uh how does she get the powers
explained okay uh yeah she got powers
okay so
the way that you know monica got powers
is when they did an x-ray of her
all they came back was just a light
source that's all that came back
was just the light source so she's
basically like living light at this
point
that's all she is it's just living light
um
that's amazing but yeah she's just
living light
that's really all it is so yeah she
definitely uh definitely got her powers
so um everybody's laughing at that guy
that guy tried to troll me i troll him
back and everybody's laughing at him now
i always wonder what's it like for a
troll like when you when you try to
troll
you get made fun of and the and like
everybody that you were trying to get to
laugh along with you starts laughing at
you like
at that point what's the point of your
life like you can't even get people to
laugh at your choke
what's the point of living if you can't
troll right
could you do anything right like that's
that's that's painful
that's just painful but uh
you probably find a book at barnes and
noble about how to troll you know i'm
sure some youtube channel will
show you somewhere i'm sure it looked
easier when you're watching it on
youtube
but um but yeah no she's basically
living light
so uh what am i vaping on i am vaping on
marketplace e-liquid which is actually
my favorite so
um but yeah let's see how does she
recognize that evan peters quicksilver
she couldn't recognize him as her
brother right see that's the question
that's the question
right because it's it's not like
it's not like he looks close to her
brother like you would
think in this this is just me talking
right if my sister died like you guys
have seen my sister you guys have seen
libby
like if my sister died then my
thought would be okay if i not even if i
created my own reality but like if
somebody popped up
i would recognize if she was my sister
or not and i feel like wanda would look
at that and be like you're not
quicksilver right and just and that
would be it
like like that would be it and and so
it's a little weird to me but see that's
the thing there's a lot of i mean okay
just because he has white hair does not
matter
right i mean i could walk down the
street and pay any swing and dick to dye
their hair white and then just be like
here you go wanda here's quicksilver you
know
it is no it doesn't
[Laughter]
it doesn't work that way so okay she was
manipulated that's my thoughts
that she that that she's not actually
seeing him the way he looks
right uh either that or we're just kind
of expected to believe that he's just
the new quicksilver and that's it right
like the the idea like darcy's statement
like
she recast quicksilver they're just kind
of like yeah i mean she recrashed
quicksilver
and expecting us as comic book fans just
kind of roll with it like it's fans who
are just like i mean you know
like expecting us to adopt the mentality
we don't really care how they get the
x-men in the mcu
as long as they're there right it could
be literally deadpool just comes
floating in with a giant balloon and
just drops them all off and then
leaves and we would just be like cool
and they're here now and that would be
it that'd be the only thing that matters
right i mean here's here's my question
here's my question
uh would you guys
yeah i've i think it's billy or billy
and tommy doing it um
would you guys want to see deadpool
float in in a giant zeppelin
like a giant like hot air balloon
drop the x-men off and leave and that's
how they're introduced into the mcu
would you would you would you think like
would you accept that
would you be like i'm okay with that and
then just enjoy the movie like would you
would you accept that
it's like yes
people are saying yes why are you saying
yes
why are you saying yes to that
people are saying that sounds amazing
i mean just right into the sunset
why i mean that's the thing that's
that's what's so crazy about deadpool
man is like he could do almost anything
right like
like literally he just pulls up in like
some old horse-drawn carriage from
little house on the prairie
and just dumps out the cast of of uh
of x-men first class and it's like here
you go guys at least here you're gonna
stand a chance to make a good movie
and then just rides off in the sunset
and like every all of us in the theaters
would be like
awesome the x-men are here now and then
we would just go forward and watch the
movie
it'd be pretty amazing it'd be pretty
amazing uh
he should give birth to professor x
don't question it um a mickey mouse hot
air balloon that would be hilarious
like that would be amazing um how did
wanda create her children i think she
created her children by just creating
them out of nothing
like she just literally fabricated them
out of nothing she just
impregnated herself and that's it right
she was just suddenly pregnant with kids
and that's all there is um i think the
reason why they're aging up so fast
is because subconsciously she knows it's
only a matter of time before all this
ends
like it's only a matter of time before
all this shuts down i think that's why
like the the time skips are happening i
think it's why we're jumping from
generate from like
you know the 50s to the 60s to the 70s
80s
just jumping through all that so fast
because it's basically a different like
it averages out it's not really
a one for one but it averages out to one
decade every episode
so yeah one is insanely powerful yeah
she can violate the laws of physics
so um i hope they go with mephisto she
can't control them
um okay do you guys
think because i've seen this fan theory
floating around
do you guys think that evan peters is
actually mephisto
pretending to be quicksilver
do you think that's the case
deadpool 3 is just wade stealing money
to pay hugh jackman to come back as well
i would i would watch that if deadpool 3
was just a giant money heist
and then like you don't know why he's
doing it then at the end he just like
goes to hugh jackman's house and drops
all the money off and it's like is this
enough to get you to come back and play
wolverine
and then it cuts to black
i would love that i would love that oh
we got a mixed crowd on this one
wow we got a mixed crowd on this one
people are saying no
so you do not think
you think director raymond is mephisto
you do not think that
any of these people that you don't you
don't think that evan peters is mephisto
okay then if one of the members in the
cast
was mephisto then who do you think it is
yeah he read my comment well that's the
hope is to read as many comments as i
can
matthew mcconaughey is mephisto i'd love
to see matthew mcconaughey as mephisto
yeah he do like those lincoln those
lincoln commercials
just like riding around like when i'm
not manipulating a demi-god crazy woman
into altering reality in a local town
i'm driving a lincoln like
that's what i would love to see i would
love to see that
you think ralph is mephisto director
jesus those answers came in
ralph or herb i don't think it's herb
agnes dottie or ralph
hmm
agnes dottie or ralph the mailman
quicksilver was brought in by doctor
strange how would he brought why would
he brought in
by doctor strange
that'd be kind of wild um
see i think dottie is too easy of a
choice
to be mephisto uh
ralph makes sense ralph makes sense for
a couple different reasons
right so
let's try to square this circle
what's another name for a marriage
give me another name for a marriage
right
a marriage between two people is a what
between two people
uh do you think aim will be involved
with all the hexagons and the beekeeper
no the bean keeper was an aim soldier
was a
um a sword guy a sword scientist
who basically went in there and then a
suit was modified by the environment
so um
doctor strange would know what's wrong a
union exactly
so a marriage is synonymous with a union
or a pact or something like that
now
said that her marriage to her the
anniversary of her marriage with ralph
is june 2nd and somebody on twitter
pointed out at one point
that june 2nd is when the salem witch
trials started
right so here's my question it may be
they're taking a totally different
approach because the marvel comics agnes
or agatha harkness is thousands of years
old
right like i think it was something like
she she was old enough to remember
when atlantis was still uh was still
like
a place that hadn't sunk right so that
means that she's as old if not older
than the second celestial host when the
celestials came back after modifying
the genes of early man which is
something like like 15 to 20 000 years
ago so
she's at least that old but let's say in
the marvel cinematic universe she's not
right let's say she's a few hundred
years old she's old enough that she was
maybe a younger woman in her 20s like
maybe the same age she is now that you
see her in the show
she was that age during the salem witch
trials
right and let's say because the because
somebody on twitter pointed out that
june
2nd in 1884 i think it is is when the
salem witch trials happened
and so let's say that that's the case
let's say that the the salem witch
trials took place
and uh did i ever upload the audio for
i never uploaded that audio okay give me
one second guys i need to upload the
audio for
[Music]
uh for agent venom
agent venom i need to upload the audio
for that um
so let's say that agnes was not a witch
at the time that she was accused but
let's say that they they assumed she was
one right they accused her of being a
witch
they were gonna burn her at the stake
right they were gonna burn her and they
were gonna kill her
and in that moment um
in that moment they say okay
like she basically begs and says you
know i would do anything or somebody
please help me or something like that
and say that like all time stops uh
1692 okay say that like all time stops
right it all just stops the fire stops
the people who are screaming and
shouting throwing things at her they all
freeze in place
everything stops and she doesn't know
what's going on even the pain goes away
right she doesn't know what's going on
or maybe like her her brain
gets or her essence gets yanked away you
know or something along those lines
i i close my twitter out um
june is the sixth month of the year um i
closed my twitter deactivated my twitter
for a while because people were getting
silly on twitter so i just got
i got annoyed with it and deactivated it
i may reactivate it at some future point
in time
but um but let's say
um i don't i don't know matpat had like
i don't really watch theory videos like
i i for real and for true i don't really
watch theory videos like i don't really
like watching three videos because
i don't want to run to that problem
people like you got that from such and
such and it's like okay like i don't
i don't like i don't like watching
theory videos i like to come up with my
own theories on this stuff
right so let's say that agatha harkness
was being burned at the stake and let's
say that
she she sold or sold them a fisto right
if she sold her soda mephisto
then that's their union right that's
when she was inexorably bound to
mephisto let's say the price she pays
is that she'll be eternally youthful
she'll never age and so
maybe like ralph was her actual husband
uh but
she'll never like like she she's just
she outlived her husband anybody she
ever loved she outlived right that's
with tormund
that's her the price she pays for making
a deal with mephisto or something along
those lines
either that or mephisto really is ralph
and the anniversary of their union or
when she made her pact with mephisto was
on june 2nd
the day the salem witch trial started
when she was going to be executed and
she basically made a deal with the devil
in order to save her life the question
is
um oh there's leaks of her getting
burned at the stake
okay um but the question is like how do
you get from that point like
even if she was being burned at the
stake and even if she made a deal with
the devil
what does wanda have to do with it why
would mephisto want wanda
right why like what's the point what's
the purpose of that
so um
it's kind of weird uh don't forget about
sword it could be a cosmic space threat
instead of demonic
that's true but sword doesn't doesn't
monitor space um that's one of the
things they established in the marvel
cinematic universe
is that it is uh the sentient weapon
observation and response department
uh not the sentient uh
not the um
sentient world observation and response
department so
um
oh it's a flashback okay uh but yeah
so uh wanda is very op but uh her power
yeah her power just allows her to warp
reality
so you think she has a power stone
because here's here's one thing to
understand
about the infinity stones the infinity
stones exist in the marvel cinematic
universe right now they exist
right they haven't been wiped from
existence
but you guys are aware of that right
like the infinity stone still exists in
the mcu
but that's the issue is right now the
only real credible evidence anybody has
when they point to the theory of
mephisto
is just that line the devil's in the
details and she's like that's not the
only place he is
but like that doesn't necessarily mean
mephisto like that one line is the only
line of logic people have
that it's mephisto so um
yeah i don't i don't yeah i don't know
so
um uh will there be a sentient world
observation responsible i don't think
there really will be so
uh dude that dog was suicidal as hell
that dog was absolutely suicidal because
the infinity stones were never destroyed
right i mean okay so so track so so
track
the timeline here with infinity war and
avengers end game
right that
thanos got the infinity stones he
snapped his fingers
blinked out half the life in in the
universe and so five years later
the avengers go back in time get the
infinity stones from different locations
in the timeline and then come back to
the present
and then undo everything thanos did and
then iron man snaps kills thanos
destroys his armies
and then dies in the process right and
so the infinity stones were taken by
captain america
back to their proper place in the
timeline and so if thanos as he was
killed in the present by iron man was
actually thanos from the past who
traveled to the present
that it means that thanos was never
there to capture the infinity stones in
the timeline
because he wasn't at that point in time
he was not he was not
at he was not on zandar taking the power
stone he was not at the collector's base
of operations of nowhere taking the
reality stone
he was in the events of avengers end
game right and so because that the
stones went back to where they were
supposed to be which means
that at the point when he was supposed
to take it from from the
from zandar and take the power stone
they weren't there
right like they just they did they
weren't there like he wasn't there
so um yeah thanos said he reduced them
to adams but that was at the beginning
that was at the beginning of the events
of infinity war
or i'm sorry of uh in-game so
uh so yeah it creates a whole different
a whole different problem but
um okay i mean even if even if like even
if they created
a different timeline right even if they
created a different timeline
then it still exists right like the
infinity stones are still there
like they're still available for people
to use
so lagos is just a city in nigeria
that's how that is unless
okay so maybe it's the days of future
past effect
right so like in the original days of
future past event
um i love figuring stuff like this out
in the original days of future past
comic book
uncanny x-men 141 and 142 with a little
bit of lead up in 137 through 139
and 140. um that
rachel summers sent the mind of kitty
pride into the past
to stop the assassination of senator
robert kelly charles xavier moore
mctaggart
which she successfully did but if she
stopped the assassination from happening
which is what caused days of future past
then how could rachel summers send the
mind of kitty pry okay
so yeah i get what you guys are saying i
get what you guys are saying
so okay yeah yeah okay i get what you
guys are saying so so you guys are
saying there's timeline a
and timeline b timeline a is everything
that happened
up to the events of infinity war and
avengers in-game until they went back in
time
timeline b is when they went back in
time so
they're still living in timeline a but
okay yeah yeah okay nevermind yeah i see
what you guys are saying i still i see
what you guys are saying
so you think evan is nightmare uh hmm
evan peters is back as quicksilver isn't
yeah it is really insane
um i don't know if the infinity stones
ever existed in the fox universe
so uh
yeah kevin foggy said the infinity
stones will no longer be a part of the
story in the mcu wow
so we're never going to see him in the
marvel cinematic universe that's smart
it avoids the issue you run into with
infinity stones and marvel comics
whether like the immediate go-to for any
time there's a crazy problem
so um
logos is a place where wakanda
accidentally kills those people in
captain america civil war yeah that's
what i'm saying it's a city in nigeria
it's where where um the fight between
the avengers and crossbones happened
so uh evan evan peters is perfect for
pietro with his charisma snappy
fast wit comebacks and power uh this
leading to marvel's wondergore for
multiverse atj
should be recast as captain britain i
mean that would be kind of funny to see
him just come back as captain britain
even though he's eastern european
um so here's my question here's my
question
would you guys prefer that evan peters
stay
in the mcu as quicksilver instead of
aaron taylor johnson whatever his name
is
would you guys prefer him or the old
quicksilver if you want the new
quicksilver say new
if you want the old quicksilver say oh i
say old
i don't really trust leaks
like i don't really trust the leaks
because according to the leaks by this
point in the series wanda would be
possessed by mephisto and should be
conquering the world so i don't really
trust the leaks that much
uh no yes
new new new new
you have a feeling wanda might be the
next big bad in the ncu i kinda hope she
will be
i'm not even gonna lie i kind of hope
that wanda maximoff is gonna be the new
villain in the marvel cinematic universe
i kind of hope that's going to be the
case
like i'm really hoping for that because
i think it'd be cool i think it'd be
awesome especially in the multiverse of
madness
if the multiverse of madness is like a
multiversal version of house of m
where she just loses her mind and she
just snaps and just lets
all this this reality warping energy
just loose across the multiverse
and everything just goes insane and it's
just dr strange
trying to get it all sorted out but then
the question becomes like
how do you end up invoking uh how does
scholar which become i mean we know
she's going to be in it but i guess
we're not we don't really know
the extent to which she's going to be in
it at this point we're just fan
theorizing
so uh disney won't do mephisto because
of china censorship has disney said
they're not going to do mephisto
have they explicitly said that or are
people just assuming that they won't
so um when do the new episodes drop the
the show comes out every friday at
midnight i'm pretty sure but i don't
usually catch it until i get up in the
morning
so do you think she'll be gray bad
should be the jolie bindo of the star
wars or the the
marvel comics universe the marvel
cinematic universe
um call owen reese yeah he'd fix those
problems in
us oh and we used to snap his fingers
and fix everything the scarlett wish did
how do you think they will do mutants in
the mcu do you think they will
they'll financially be able to get
another x-mansion do you think it will
constantly be destroyed again
no i think they're gonna they're gonna
handle them a lot more delicately than
what we've seen them do in the marvel
cinema and in the fox
universe i think i don't think they're
going to treat them as just kind of a
thing that's there and you know just
kind of throwing it around
i think they'll treat it with a lot more
respect and a lot more care um
i hope so anyway so uh
who would tell wanda um
who would tell wanda where is vision
someone might tell her
if she brings his body will help her
bring him back
but when she brings them back they put
her into the text
oh so like you know bring bring vision's
body to me and i will help you resurrect
him and then in turn they just
conquer they they take over her i guess
but again like that's that's the biggest
issue that i run into is what's the
benefit of that
like what's what's what's the benefit in
all of that right how does it how does
it benefit them to do that
so um for what hero should want to be a
villain for
uh that's the thing wanda is powerful
enough
she could be a villain for like the
whole marvel cinematic universe
right and that's the question is how do
you stop somebody on that level
i mean here's the thing to understand
the original house of immigrant it
wasn't as though wanda was defeated
and somebody like the molecule man or
something like that undid
everything she did she set it back
herself and just said no more mutants in
the process
so it was her doing that set everything
back to normal don't forget that like
she's the one that adjusted everything
back so
you know nobody was really able to stop
her um
only way to somehow control her i mean i
don't know maybe they can just grab one
of those mutant inhibitor colors she
makes it in the animated series just
slap them on her on her
neck and just make her girl work in
genosha by herself for until the day she
dies
i have no idea um the
spanish portuguese translation uses the
female adjective for aerospace engineer
for when monica is talking you think
this could be sue storm
well that's the thing like like
aerospace engineer
is it's a an asexual term right it
doesn't really ascribe to any particular
gender
um or any particular sex rather so
it does not inherently mean a guy or
girl it simply just
is there right it's just it just exists
um so it can be assigned to either one
and my editor texted me give me one
second guys i'm sorry
uh
let's see okay yeah it doesn't it
doesn't inherently lead towards
one one or another it's not as though
you you know like susan storm
is a genetic engineerist right you know
that's not really not really what it
means or an aerospace engineer it's not
really what that is
uh there's no real no real uh you know
sex based
assignment to that particular word so
um do i expect to see deadpool and juan
division no
i don't expect to see deadpool on one of
mission it'd be amazing if we did
but i don't expect to see deadpool in
one division
um let's see dr strange will get wrecked
against wanda i'm telling you i think so
too
like i really think i really think he
would all right guys we're gonna do this
for a couple more minutes then i'm gonna
bounce off here
um i do want to keep these live streams
relatively short about half an hour or
so i don't really want to go too long
um but let's see
uh i think wanda isn't the villain i
think the head of sword is a villain
what is the meaning of sword in one
division and what could vision be in the
wrong hands
as a sentient weapon i guess so but it
doesn't really strike me as him being a
villain
right i mean i think he's incompetent
but i don't really think he's a villain
i think he's kind of an idiot uh you
think wanda brought evan peter from the
fox universe
multiverse yeah i'm i'm down with that
like i totally agree with that
um i definitely think that's the case uh
daryl's just spamming the hell out of
the chat evan peters is mephisto
looking at evan peters other past
characters a lot of them are very
charismatic
and see my goofy but immensely evil and
cold underneath it all
that has that's his character's bread
and butter i mean i guess
but like he seems like i mean he wasn't
like that in days of future past he
wasn't
it wasn't as though he was like just
evil underneath trying to kill the x-men
otherwise he would have let him all die
in the explosion in
x-men apocalypse like he would have
showed up there and be like oh awesome
my work's cut out for me and just stand
there and watch while they all die
screaming and
and crying you know but um
they introduced century to south the
wanda stop wanda i don't think that's
gonna happen
uh sparky's mephisto that'd be amazing
if sparky the dog turned out to be
mephisto
i mean i wouldn't put it past that in
the original century comic by paul
jenkins and jaylee the boy took on the
form of a dog
right so like demonic dogs like we've
seen that before in comics it's not
outside the realm of possibility um how
do i think doctor strange will win when
he went against thanos with multiple
stones
and she went against thanos with zero um
that's the question to ask man that's
the question to ask because right now by
all standards of measurement
wanda exceeds the power of the infinity
gauntlet
right assuming that everything that you
see going on there is actually her
she has the power to dominate the minds
of others she has the power to rewind
time
she has the power to alter reality to
just make things change to make things
look different than they really are
to make things appear out of nowhere
she's a walking talking infinity
gauntlet
right that's what she is she's able to
alter and control
every facet of reality across the board
so um that that's really all that is
like and and that's the thing like you
had thanos with
the um with the power stone
just demolishing doctor strange and
everybody else
right so uh what do the mailman mean
that nobody leaves the town unless wanda
lets them
i think that was just more of an
offhanded remark illustrating the fact
that wanda's mom
i'm sorry juana doesn't let anybody
leave uh unless she wants them too right
they're all trapped there
basically uh do i think the mc will use
the same actress from fox's deadpool for
the character of negasonic
i don't think so i don't think they'll
do that it'd be interesting if they did
but i don't really think they will okay
one more question guys and then i'm
gonna i'm gonna
call it a day i'm gonna call it a day um
let's see all right if you guys have
questions spam your questions in the
chat
spam your questions in the chat and then
i will ask you guys this final question
um do you guys
like wanda vision so far if you had to
give one division a number rating what
would you give it one through five
what number would you give it
there's that one person who's trolling
they're gonna put like a one or
something like that
but um
let's see did monica rambo text blue
marvel
i don't think so but i hope so i would
love it if she did if she texted adam
rasheer and we're gonna get adam in the
marvel cinematic universe
i think it's more likely she texted reed
richards i think that's the most likely
scenario
that she texted reed richards like i'm
pretty sure that's the case
and it'd definitely be cool if we got to
see it so
i would definitely be down for that but
uh
okay wow every single number that
somebody typed in
is being hidden every single one
okay i may have just got my own stream
demonetized when it uploads
youtube automatically demonetizes live
streams i don't know why
but they automatically demonetize them
so it's probably because their algorithm
and youtube's lazy so um okay so instead
of doing that
instead of doing the numbers um okay
cool all the numbers are going through i
guess though
it ended up holding the numbers of
people who were just spamming
arbitrarily over the course
of the stream um okay so i'm seeing a
lot of fours a lot of five somebody put
an eight
you know i don't know
[Laughter]
we'll just break it down like a fraction
and we'll divide it in half and call it
a four
so um but yeah i see a lot of a lot of
fours and fives and that's cool
because i love one division as well it's
the most exciting thing i've seen on
television in quite some time
uh it's a great show and what i really
love about it is the mystery
right solving the riddle of what's going
on like that's that's the coolest part
so anyway guys i'm going to go ahead and
bounce off here uh thank you guys for
joining me on this journey to
watch uh wanda vision and talk about it
and all that kind of cool stuff we'll do
this again next week
um i will actually i don't think we're
gonna be able to do it next week myself
and myself and
i are heading out of town next week for
uh valentine's
oh pardon me valentine's day uh we're
actually heading down to cincinnati so
we will not be able to do this next week
i'll actually be out of town but
uh but yeah thanks for coming out guys
it was cool hanging out with you guys
and i will catch you all later peace
maybe kind of uh i'll have to go back to
the control room and then turn off the
stream okay cool i will catch you guys
later
peace